[Music]
hi everyone judge andrew napolitano here
with judging freedom today is thursday
august 11 2022 it's about five o'clock
in the afternoon
here on the east coast of the united
states
uh my guest is one of my favorite
physicians with whom i love to speak dr
joel wallach dr wallach is an
internationally recognized naturopathic
physician
his uh his goal in his life's work has
been
to to stimulate the body to stimulate
nature so that the body will heal itself
as we speak
my producer will be putting up
judginghealth.com
which is the website that dr wallach
created for judging freedom viewers
from which you can
choose to order a variety
of supplements and medications all of
which personally
created and crafted by uh by dr wallach
and you can also
speak with people uh who work with and
for dr wallach who can guide you through
uh the various
i think correct me if i'm wrong dr
wallach thousands of options available
to them for their various ailments dr
wallick it's a pleasure
uh welcome here
well thank you your honor it's an honor
to be talking with you and and your
followers and listeners um thank you
thank you today i want i want you to
talk about
arthritis i want you to tell us what
arthritis is what the various three or
four or five types of arthritis are sure
and then i'm going to ask you
after you've come up for a little bit of
air uh what mainstream medicine
and big pharma prescribe for arthritis
and what you
prescribe to stimulate the body
to cure its own arthritis
okay well well said great questions
thank you so much your honor it's it's
an honor to be with you and i can't
thank you enough for the opportunity to
share with your followers
well first of all the population united
states is 332 million 228 200.
there there's 58.5 million cases of
active
arthritis in the united states and
arthritis
is a degenerative
state of the joint
specifically of the joints osteoporosis
includes the joints and the lung bones
but arthritis is just a degeneration
of the joints the cartilage and the
bones and the ligaments and tendons and
so forth
and
um
back i want to go back to like
um 1850 1890 and ricketts was a terrible
thing which was simply arthritis and
kids they had bold legs and
arthritis in their hips and knees and
backs and stuff was a mess
and then in 1920 some nutritionists
began to put vitamin d3 on milk
um dairy cow milk that was on the
shelves in in the stores
1920-1923 and we eliminated
um arthritis in kids we eliminated
the
rickets and kids which is arthritis in
kids okay
24 of americans have arthritis 58.5
million cases
uh juvenile arthritis right now has come
back it says 16 16 year old we have 300
000 at any one time active
uh
300 000 active cases of arthritis in 16
year olds and younger
how would 16 year olds get arthritis
it's not contagious how do they get it
well it's a nutritional deficiency
disease
and instead of drinking the milk off the
shelf with the vitamin d3 in it they're
drinking colas there's no nutrition in
colas okay and that's why it's coming
back in the kids
okay
and so that was a very good question you
asked
okay now there's three million
um cases of juvenile arthritis in the
world under the age of 16. three million
cases okay which is what they used to be
called rickets
and then
um there's rheumatoid arthritis okay r.a
uh doctors once you believe that's an uh
autoimmune disease the body's attacking
itself but rheumatoid arthritis is just
a simple nutritional deficiency
arthritis with a secondary infection
with a bug called mycoplasma which is
killable with a antibody called
menocycline like the bait fish
menominocycline
but that's a that's a
um prescription drug so you have to get
a six weeks prescription from your
doctor
and then you use that along with our
healthy bone and joint pack
and
rheumatoid arthritis will go away in two
to six weeks even if you've had it for
45 years it's not an autoimmune disease
it's not a genetic disease
it's very simple
infection on top of a nutritional
deficiency arthritis
right now each year in america just to
treat arthritis symptoms not to prevent
it or cure it just to treat the symptoms
judge we're spending 620
billion dollars just to treat the
symptoms of arthritis so big pharma
loves that oh big pharma loves it
orthopedic surgeons love it doctors in
general practice love it
okay and it's because it's a very simple
nutritional deficience disease
and the
doctors treat it by
giving the patient cortisone prednisone
and of course it's the patients love it
oh i love my doctor had such joint pain
forever and he gave me cortisone and
prednisone and the pain went away in
three days
i'm going to leave everything in my will
to my my doctor because i love how
together
but the doctor is still milking the
dairy cow right
right
okay
and then
uh lupus is kind of a
thing that goes along with that
okay um
lupus is uh a joint disease a skin
disease also involves the intestines
irritable syndrome and skin disease
and so
what what i like to do
for arthritis and
as its basic thing is to give the body
the nutrients it needs to maintain
itself
we need 90 essential nutrients and our
program for arthritis no matter what
type you have the basic program is you
need
the 90th century nutrients so we have
our big hammer i call it which covers
something like 600 different diseases
it's called the healthy brain and heart
pack okay it has 215 nutrients in it
including the 90 essential nutrients
which everybody knows about 60 minerals
16 vitamins 12 minutes to 3 fatty acids
but the healthy brand heart pack has 215
nutrients including that the primary 90
essential nutrients and then i want them
to have our msm
uh i want two bottles a month of msm's
they can take three at breakfast through
atlanta street at a time and they're
designed to provide the minerals
necessary to make cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
your vertebrae bone breaks with bone
cells including bone marrow
to make white blood cells platelets red
blood cells and antibodies for your
immune system
okay a couple of questions how would how
would a person say let's say i had
stiffness in my wrist in my hand let's
just use me as the
example how would i know
what to take would your website
help negotiate me through that do i have
to consult with you or with with someone
else and how long would i have to take
these supplements for
okay i'm gonna start at the end and go
forward how long do you need to take the
supplements well how long do you need
oxygen judge forever
okay how long do you need water
okay
how long do you need the 90s potential
nutrients see the problem is nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth
they occur in veins like gold and silver
and so you can be eating the same recipe
that your twin brother twin sister is
taking and they're living in
pennsylvania and they're getting say 25
minerals and you're living in arizona
and you're only getting three
so i'm getting the same thing how come
i'm getting arthritis here and my sister
isn't
we're eating the same recipe that
grandma gave us well in the old days
grandma used to make bone broth i don't
know if you're old enough to remember
bone broth
why still drink bone broth okay
okay and you put chicken bones and fish
bones and things like that and rib bones
and vinegar on top of the wood stove all
night we'd fight over who's going to get
to drink it because we knew it was good
for your joints and your bones and
everything
and so we came up with what we call
the
collagen peptides which is collagen from
fish poultry sheep and beef and it takes
the place of the
bone broth so people don't have to make
it we've already made it for them okay
and you want to take a scoop of that
with your morning drink and your scoop
of that with your evening drink and
that's going to regrow cartilage and
ligaments and tendons it also regrows
your skin it regrows the
connective tissue
uh in your
intestines your arteries your veins so
collagen peptides is very very good it's
kind of like bone broth in the old days
okay okay
now osteoporosis is the same thing as
arthritis but it affects the long bones
primarily as opposed to the joints
now in you take the united states canada
and the eu european union together each
year we spend just to treat the symptoms
judge again not to prevent it or cure it
osteoporosis just to treat the symptoms
between these three communities we spend
6.5 trillion dollars
that's 2.2 trillion dollars from each
um
just to make the body feel better but
not to make the body get better
you cannot repair yourself with their
treatment for osteoporosis which is
cortisone and prednisone and that kind
of stuff
okay women
in the united states have four times as
much or five times as much osteoporosis
as men
the women population female population
america is 19.6 percent have um
osteoporosis and men in america have 4.4
percent have osteoporosis and that's
because women
eat a very strict diet because you want
to have nice skin and don't gain weight
and all this kind of stuff and men are
like highness men eat everything and so
they're getting but whether they're
thinking about it or not they're getting
a lot of nutrition because they're
eating so many different things that
women won't eat and so that's why they
have one-fifth of the rate of
osteoporosis as women it's not a gender
thing it's not a genetic thing
so
um uh we uh have these programs i've
been doing this for over 50 years uh
i've dealt with this with so many
professional um uh athletes in every
sport you can think of in the world
and we've helped them some of them
like um uh
oh
let's see here
oh gosh you can't remember his name okay
um we're talking about
um
a basketball player okay
who played for the the um
uh
hawks okay
and uh he was playing for them he's only
24 years old but had bone bone arthritis
in both his knees and cartilage popped
off his hip he fractured his wrists
and they took away his 35 million dollar
contract i made the ultimate
that hurt
that hurt and so then i made the the
program for him
um with the 90th century nutrients in
the healthy bone and joint pack
and
um
he came back and played for uh
uh
let's see 11 more years and made a
hundred million dollars just taking my
program
wow
okay wow and so we have so many
um athletes in every sport boxing um
football basketball
um baseball
uh
swimming every sport you can think of if
they use our products they always come
in first and when it comes to risk it
could be osteoporosis it could be
arthritis of the wrist but could also be
osteoporosis of the skull squeezing the
spinal cord and the nerves that go to
your arms and your wrists are being
pinched
because of osteoporosis skull
okay
and so it's one of those things where
um
you take these programs and do it
correctly and stay away from the bad
foods saying maximize absorption no
gluten no wheat boiler oats no
carbonated drinks
and you'll maximize absorption if you're
drinking carbonated drinks two or three
or four times a day you're neutralizing
your stomach acid so you cannot absorb
minerals or digest food
okay if you're eating fried foods
whether it's air fried
deep fried pan fried
you're causing
all kinds of oxidation inflammation
to your tissues so you cannot absorb
things if you're eating gluten wheat
broth around oats you know people
grandma you see
um oatmeal for breakfast every morning
for 30 years
but it damages your intestines so you
cannot absorb nutrients
okay so you cannot help if we
if a
viewer watching and listening to you now
had an ailment again i'll use myself a
little stiffness in the wrist
how would they know what to take i mean
they go to the website does the website
ask them
questions that they would answer and the
result is a
is a is a supplement for them or do they
talk to a human being do they talk to
you how does this work
uh they can talk to a human being if
they want to uh we also on this website
we have books
um let's play doctor dead doctors don't
lie
um
doctor always cooking without the bad
foods hell's kitchen
these sort of things it's all in your
head we have 21 best-selling books
that you can get off the website and
they deal with the great detail of all
these diseases
and um
what i like we have a book is called
rare earths adventures
and it goes into how to get a hair
analysis so it teaches you how to get a
hair analysis and you get two charts for
the hair analysis hair analysis tells
you
um
if you if you're in the right range for
all your nutritional minerals that are
necessary for your bones and your skin
and your arteries your connective tissue
and so forth and also it tells you if
you have toxic metals like lead and
mercury and uranium and other toxic
metals and that way you know how you're
starting out and so i like the book rare
spin cures and it covers most of the
mineral deficiency diseases which
include you know all of the bone and
cartilage and ligament diseases and so
on
and so it's one of those things where
we deal
with over 600 different diseases we have
5 000 products and people can we have
various price ranges so they can
actually uh deal with this and if they
uh join us
and and say okay we're going to join
with
the judge napolitano and be part of his
group uh we'll give them a wholesale
price on all the products if they got an
auto ship your honor i will get i will
pay the shipping for them if they get on
auto shipping i pay the shipping save
and instead of
masking the arthritis
with something that makes them feel good
they'll be stimulating their own body
to rid themselves to cure the body of
the arthritis a profound profound
to me as a as a
simple lawyer not a doctor a profound
difference
yeah and you get an a plus because
you've hit the nail on the head sir as
usual that's why everybody loves you
you know how to hit the nail on the head
you're a very good observer
that um we've been doing this for a long
time and the advantage i have sir um i
had a degree in agriculture and
nutrition i had a degree in veterinary
medicine i have a post-doctoral
fellowship in pathology my thesis is in
the smithsonian institute as a national
treasure
oh the okay they sell for twenty five
thousand dollars each a summary of that
summary of that thesis um epigenetics
the death of jack theory z transmission
is a summary of it sells for 25 bucks
goes into about 25 different major
disease including arthritis and
osteoporosis okay and
um it's only 25 bucks instead of 25 000.
you get the same information
and if you go to the i have so many
people go to the um
the museum okay
and they want to see my thesis because
they can't believe my thesis is in the
smithsonian institute so they have to go
with two guards because people have been
stealing those books and so they have to
go with two guards so that they don't
steal the books all right dr wallach
uh when you come back
what will we talk about next diabetes
how about that next week you got it sir
that's one of my favorite subjects and
we'll be able to do a great job okay so
the website is judging health dot com
that's what it looks like when you first
log on and you can navigate your way
through
and you can even talk to an expert
who'll guide you
towards the medications that are
appropriate for the symptoms you're
discussing dr joel wallock
one of our regulars on judging freedom
it's always a pleasure thank you so much
dear sir
well thank you so much your honor you
are the greatest we love you so many
people love you and respect you god
bless you sir thank you judge napolitano
for judging freedom
[Music]
you